a new poll says the president Trump will
lose to every major Democrat running for
president even Cory Booker does that
mean that Trump's re-election chances
are doomed we will take a look back on
some of our favorite polls and election
predictions from 2016 then Democrats
Watergate testimony flops in Congress
and a jury orders an American University
to shell out 11 million dollars to a
bakery that it wrongly smeared we will
analyze the high price of social justice
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are not gonna believe the latest
polls I mean that very literally you are
not going to believe them because
they're absolutely ridiculous but we
will take a look first support for the
Michael Knowles show comes from our
friends at rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans finding the right house is not
easy you are telling me I wander around
LA I look at all these nice houses and
they're everything either there's seven
zillion dollars or there's something
wrong with them or it's hard to get
financing or it's hard to do this or do
that
finding the right mortgage can be very
difficult but rocket mortgage is doing
more to help you understand the home
buying process so you can get exactly
what you need because it's not just a
mortgage it's your mortgage and they
have found a better way their team of
mortgage experts is obsessed with
finding a better way which means that
their number one goal is to make the
home buying process smoother for you you
know if you've ever even looked at homes
you know how difficult this can be
rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way Quicken Loans has
helped millions of Americans achieve
their dreams of homeownership and when
you are ready to purchase the home of
your dreams they can help you too when
you work with them you get more than
just alone because rocket mortgage is
more than just a lender get started
online right now at rocket mortgage.com
slash Knolls KO wles
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states nmls consumer access org number
30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage a shock poll out
just today from Quinnipiac University
this is not a poll of who's winning the
2020 Democrat primary contest this is a
poll that shows head-to-head how people
would vote when someone gets the
nomination and they run against
President Trump so the poll shows that
Joe Biden beats Donald Trump 53 to 40 I
don't know where that other 7% goes
maybe it goes to like Bill weld or
somebody may Ron Paul is gonna run again
I don't know 53 to 40 bad news for Trump
huh shows that Bernie Sanders in in
second here is going to beat Donald
Trump 51 to 42
still totally decisive now maybe this is
plausible I mean those two guys have
been running at the top of the pack for
a long time in the Democrat race okay
then it shows Kamala Harris beats Donald
Trump 49 to 41 that's your I'm buying
that Liz Warren beats Donald Trump 49 to
40 - Pete Budaj age 47
beats Donald Trump 42 even at this point
I'm thinking I guess maybe this is
plausible I guess pop me I don't know
what the polls say and then I just
stopped believing it at all because this
poll shows that Cory Booker beats Donald
Trump 47 to 42 that is not possible
Cory Booker is never going to be
President he is most certainly never
going to run against Donald Trump and
he's never going to be done from this is
pretty wacky but it reminds us of an
important truth about these polls and
these predictions and and everything
they're the experts are telling us now
which is that it's not reliable this is
not reliable yet don't forget in 2016 I
was reminded of one of my favorite
stories this was being reported from The
Huffington Post from the independent all
over the mainstream media and it was
based on a study that came out of
Princeton for instance an Ivy League
university so surely those experts know
what they're talking about the headline
read and the independent survey finds
Hillary Clinton has quote more than 99%
chance of winning election over Donald
Trump the Princeton election consortium
found miss Clinton has a projected 312
electoral votes across the country and
only 270 are needed to win the
probability statistic was found by the
university's statistical Bayesian model
oh gosh Bayesian that sounds serious
other polls were less bullish on a
Clinton victory 538 said the likelihood
of Ms Clinton that winning was 65% while
the New York Times upshot said there was
an 85 percent chance okay the the polls
show between 65 to 99% chance that
Hillary Clinton wins what happened is
that 1% turned out to
correct huffington post reported another
similar story they said of post
forecasts Hillary Clinton will win with
332 electoral votes Democrats stand a
strong chance of taking control of the
Senate as well how did that turn out
have the Democrats to give grandma grads
still don't have the Senate The
Huffington Post presidential forecast
model gives Democrat Hillary Clinton a
ninety eight point two percent chance of
winning the presidency see they were a
little more conservative they didn't say
ninety nine percent they reduced that
number by 0.8 percent Republican Donald
Trump has essentially no path to an
electoral college victory
so the Princeton version said that
Hillary would get 312 electoral votes to
270 Huffington Post said that Hillary
would get 323 electoral votes what
happened in reality
Donald Trump won 304 electoral votes
Hillary only got 227 the idea that cory
booker is going to be donald trump is
ridiculous it is absurd on its face
frankly even the idea that joe biden is
going to beat Donald Trump is crazy and
and Joe Biden is far and away the
front-runner right now but does anyone
actually think he's likely to win the
presidency I'm not saying he can't win
he could win does anyone think Joe Biden
is likely to win this guy was chased out
in 1988 for lies and plagiarism he lost
in 2008 because he was a weak candidate
now he's being accused of plagiarism
again he was he obviously plagiarized
his climate change platform from other
left-wing environmental groups actually
just this week he is plagiarizing
Michael avenatti on a themed campaign
motto for his campaign he is now saying
that we don't need to make America great
again we need to make America America
again look I don't think it's naive I
don't think it's all fashion way of
doing things that says the system has to
be restored you know - I think it's time
to
you know he says let's make America
great again let's make America America
again okay Wow this is not a great
slogan by the way because it's just
reacting to Donald Trump it's reacting
to Trump's slogan make America great
again so Trump is still in the stronger
position here Joe is just setting
himself up as someone attacking Donald
Trump instead of offering something
himself but then we found out apparently
he cribbed that line from Michael
avenatti the disgraced lawyer who pimped
out stormy Daniels and apparently didn't
pay very much so he steals this line
from avenatti a Vinod he goes on Twitter
and says you took my line I thought of
it first actually it turns out that both
of them stole the line from Scott Baio
who was endorsing Donald Trump at the
2016 Republican National Convention so
of course let's make America great again
but let's make America America again you
got a good job Scott so what this means
for 2020 is that the Democrats best
chance their top candidate they're far
and away frontrunner is a guy who's
parroting Michael avenatti parroting
Scott Baio that's the best they've got
but the polls say it's all over Biden's
got it everyone's got every Democrat
will win but Biden especially will win
that's the experts that's the scientists
I'm gonna make a prediction now it won't
matter if and when these predictions are
incorrect it won't change anything the
left won't stop making these predictions
the people who bought them won't stop
believing the people who made them the
left never has to apologize for wrong
predictions a perfect example of this
came out just the other day from ABC
News I don't know who dredged it up it
was probably media Research Center
somebody like that they dug up this clip
from 2008 so 11 years ago of ABC News
predicting the end of the world if we
don't get serious about global warming
100 years from now
New York is abandoned I picture some
explorer coming to Manhattan saying
those ignorant people how on earth could
have ever expected to we have a chance
to get it right we have a chance to move
in the right direction now I don't think
that window of opportunity is gonna be
open very long one can hope that
suddenly society will realize that its
own a doomsday path and change very
rapidly it's June 8th 2015 one carton of
milk is $12.99 I'm scared as hell right
now but I have to get this out if we
continue on the business-as-usual
trajectory there will be a tipping point
that we cannot offer we will indeed
drive the car over the cliff so this is
the tipping point we're not gonna be
able to afford milk we're not gonna be
able to afford gas it's all gonna be
over gas is gonna be 11 dollars a gallon
something like that you know what gas
actually cost in 2015 they were
predicting the seven years have cost two
dollars and 40 cents a gallon it cost
eighty one-and-a-half percent less than
they predicted it would how about gallon
of milk gallon of milk was supposed to
cost $9 a gallon in 2015 well we have
the numbers we've lived past 2015 in
2015 a gallon of milk in the United
States cost on average three dollars and
31 cents a gallon that 63 percent
cheaper than was predicted his ABC news
have to run a big retraction should they
do the people who appeared in that video
I have to say oh we were wrong no what
happens now is the left says oh they
yeah that was crazy they didn't know
what they were talking about but global
warming is still SuperDuper serious yeah
they're there that's those people okay
they're wrong but the people who are
making the same predictions today
they're right those people in the video
they weren't science
they're not serious people actually they
were there were some of the leading
scientists and scientific policy makers
in the country we'll get to that in a
second but first I have got to tell you
about an absolutely incredible new
product that I just got I gave it to my
step-brother for his wedding my
step-brother recently got married and so
I have this new sponsor paint your life
calm and paint your life what they do is
you upload a photo that you like of you
or your family or friend or something
and they will create a painting of that
photo and it can be watercolor it can be
oil it can be whatever kind you want I
did an oil painting I was a photo from
my stepbrothers wedding and I thought I
don't know this is some online service
we'll see how it looks I'm not I'm not
expecting that much paint your life calm
then takes this photo that you sent them
they make an actual painting done by
hand by a world-class artist just
created from your favorite photo so they
send you a proof they kind of work with
you along the way if you don't like how
it is then you can send them feedback
you can check out every single detail
until it's perfect no risk at all they
then shipped this painting I just saw it
it is absolutely incredible I am now
gonna use this for many of my other
friends it is an incredible product and
you'd think it would be super duper
expensive it is not it makes a truly
special gift for someone you love or for
yourself I'm gonna try to upload a video
of my step brother and his wife seeing
this just an amazing product it is so
cool right now as a limited time offer
you can get 30% off your painting and
they're not that expensive to begin with
now you get 30% off do this it's any
it's an incredible product get it for
yourself get it for your family or get
it for a friend and give it out as a
gift
free shipping there's no risk if you
don't like the painting if you reject it
you'll get a refund it is no risk
unbelievably cool get it well you can
especially with this offer the way to
get this offer do it right now is to
text knowles to 48 48 48 that's KO wles
2 48 48 48 KN o wles for 8 for 8 for 8
message and data rates may apply
SuperDuper cool product so that video
about how climate change is going to
destroy the world and gases
gonna be $11 and milk is gonna be $9 who
was predicting all that stuff was it
just some wacko no well yes but it so
happens that these are expert totally
established people one of those guys was
John Holdren John Holdren was Barack
Obama's top science advisor in the White
House he was the director of the White
House Office of Science and Technology
Policy
he was the co-chairman of the
President's Council of Advisors on
science and technology
this guy was top of the heap for science
policy also the Teresa and John Heinz
professor of environmental policy at the
Kennedy School of Government at Harvard
University again
I don't just because someone works at
Harvard doesn't mean I take them
seriously especially if they're the
Teresa and John Heinz professor Teresa
Heinz you will remember is the wife of
John Kerry the former losing Democrat
presidential nominee but this guy has
all the credentials he's the scientist
he's a real scientist he's the real
policymaker top policymaker at the White
House and yet he was so completely dead
wrong he appeared in a news documentary
that was just completely ridiculous so
what is going on the purpose of these
predictions is not to warn you it's not
to predict what's actually going to
happen
it is to create a panic and then get us
socialism by the backdoor this sounds
almost conspiratorial if if I didn't
have the video I wouldn't have to
believe me
but it just keeps happening all the
predictions from the late 60s to the 70s
to the 80s the whole world is going to
end in ten years if you don't give us
socialism and then what happens ten
years goes by and the world doesn't end
and everything's perfectly fine and
their predictions are all wrong and they
tell us no but it's really gonna end in
ten years if you don't give us socialism
it's all about taking control of your
property of your liberty of your
government it is about coincidentally
they say this this environmental
catastrophe that's going to destroy the
world just coincidentally requires that
you have to give the political left
every single policy they wanted for a
hundred years that's the only way to
solve it and save the world and this is
why just a little bit of a side note
there was a piece
The Wall Street Journal that came out
today said some Republican lawmakers
break with their party on climate change
so the GOP has not taken climate change
or global warming or global cooling or
whatever you want to call it today very
seriously because they have understood
as I have just explained that it is
socialism by the backdoor
now some younger Republicans want to be
super hip cool guys or something and say
that we have to take global warming
seriously we don't this is a special
nature of Matt Gaetz he's a Republican
lawmaker I actually like the guy I think
generally he's pretty good he's just
dead wrong on this Matt Gaetz
was the one who a couple months ago
offered the green real deal and he was
going to have the Republican response to
take on global warming it's just a bad
move this is not to say that Republicans
shouldn't take the environment seriously
of course we should protect the
environment every Republican I know
wants to protect the environment
conserve the environment have beautiful
public spaces having beautiful spaces
and preserving nature is a very
conservative virtue conservatives
conserve but that's not the same thing
as global warming it's a very different
thing than global warming these global
warming is not about environmental
protection it's just about socialism the
purpose of these predictions whether
it's this guy from the Obama
administration or its aoc saying the
world is going to end in nine or ten
years just give us all your money the
purpose of it is to demoralize people
the purpose of it is to convince people
that everything is predetermined there
it's no coincidence that right now so
much of the left is denying free will
you see it in sam harris you see it in
the New Atheists you see it in a ton of
the left-wing Silicon Valley it's in the
pop culture we're being told our free
will as an illusion really we're just
drawn by unconscious forces our emotion
is leading is this anything but will the
left has always done this this is
nothing new this is not some cool new
futuristic idea out of Silicon Valley
the left has said this forever the early
socialists and communists 100 150 years
ago they said that they had discovered
the science of his
they used this phrase the science of
history this is the famous reporter
Lincoln Steffens who visited the Soviet
Union he famously said I've seen the
future and it works there's the future
history is not moved by the individual
choices of individuals it's moved by
great environmental economic forces that
we cannot control were just brought
along on the tides of history and
actually the modern conservative
movement in the United States after
World War two founded by William F
Buckley Jr was set up exactly in
opposition to this idea so you had
Lincoln Steffens saying I've seen the
future and it works the socialist saying
this is the future this is the science
of history get ready get on board and
then you have the conservative William F
Buckley Jr who said in the first issue
of National Review he said a
conservative is one who stands at wart
history yelling stop
oh you socialists and communists you
think you have the science of history
you think there's no stopping it I'm a
conservative and I'm gonna stand here
and I am going to say stop and that's
what we're doing we're saying no will
does matter your predictions don't come
true
you don't know the science of history
you don't know the future your
predictions are bogus and you're not
going to use those crazy fear-mongering
predictions to get us to give up our
Liberty and our property and our freedom
when left-wing schemes go wrong they
never have to apologize 99% Hilary's
gonna win Cory Booker is gonna beat
Donald Trump get gas is gonna be eleven
dollars a gallon although everything's
gonna happen what happens when it
doesn't come true they move on to the
next prediction almost never do they
have to apologize but I say almost
because there is one excellent story out
of Ohio in which the left had to
apologize for their aggression their
overreaction their social justice their
all of their actions recently this is a
terrific story out of Oberlin College
which I'll get to in a second but first
if you don't know your numbers then you
don't know your business
the problem the growing businesses have
and that often keeps them from knowing
their numbers is they just have a ton of
different business systems so they have
one system for accounting
they've another one for sales they've
another one for inventory they have all
these different systems and they don't
talk to each other and they can't keep
track of it and it just hurts your
business it's a big inefficient mess and
it takes up a lot of time and you know
this if you've ever worked at a small
business started a business time is
money time is resources that hurts the
bottom line this brings us to NetSuite
by Oracle the business management
software that handles every aspect of
your business
in an easy-to-use cloud platform it
gives you the visibility and control
that you need to grow this is one of
these things I think people overlook if
they're just a little lazy or they're
kind of stuck in their old ways and it's
really hampering their growth but they
just don't want to have to deal with it
with NetSuite you save time money and
unneeded headaches by managing sales
finances and accounting orders HR
instantly right from your desktop or
phone just do it don't be lazy don't get
stuck in your old ways that are costing
you money
that's why NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna wles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna
wles
download your free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits NetSuite
comm slash Knowles canna wles
rarely does the left have to apologise
when it gets things wrong but today we
have one of those rare examples an Ohio
jury is ordering Oberlin College to pay
11 million dollars to a bakery that it
libeled is racist and racially profiling
and bigoted this is Gibson's bakery and
market just outside the school a couple
years ago now a student Jonathan Aladdin
was accused of attempted robbery for it
for allegedly trying to quote steal wine
or otherwise illegally obtained wine
from the bakery he was there with two of
his buddies they were
arrested and accused of misdemeanor
assault okay no big deal college kids
all the time for either try to buy booze
illegally or maybe they try to lift it
afterward this became a big deal because
the Oberlin College staff decided to get
super social just to see about it and
this includes not just low-level staff
members this is Dean's and professors
and they gathered together a bunch of
students and they had massive
demonstrations in front of this bakery
calling them racists calling them
bigoted the vice president and Dean of
Students Meredith Raimondo and other
college staff members handed out
hundreds and hundreds of copies of a
flier that said don't buy all capital
letters this is a racist establishment
with a long account of racial profiling
and discrimination and then this Dean of
Students listed a number of competitors
to the bakery that students could shop
at obviously this cost the bakery a ton
of business and the bakery sued now why
did they sue because three months after
all this happened in August of 2017 that
student al Adam and India Lawrence
another student pled guilty to attempted
theft and aggravated trespass according
to court documents they pled guilty to
the crime that the bakery accused them
of this is what the student wrote quote
this unfortunate incident was triggered
by an attempt to purchase alcohol
I believe the employees of Gibsons
actions were not racially motivated they
were merely trying to prevent an
underage sales it's a student himself
that never let the facts get in the way
of a good social justice narrative
instead not just the students not just
some idiot professors that Dean of
Students the administration of Oberlin
decided to try to destroy this business
based on lies based on nothing since
that story came out and since the jury
in this case forced Oberlin to pay 11
million bucks in damages to that bakery
do you know what Oberlin's university
has to say for itself absolutely nothing
nothing at all this is a
perfect story Oberlin College is now
gonna pay for the cost of social justice
and I love it I think that the way that
they should try to recoup this 11
million dollars in losses is by firing
the administrator who caused it and
other administrators as well so much of
the problem at our colleges right now is
administrative bloat you have deans and
deputy deans and deputy assistant Dean's
of diversity and students and inclusion
whose entire job it is to stir up
trouble and create problems and stir up
politics this is that it's the
administration that's Jenning this sort
of thing up and they provide an awful
example for students they not only Mis
educate students they they indoctrinate
them in terrible ideas and this this
affects the academic front too they whip
up these frenzies
I mean it's happened to me I was
physically assaulted at the University
of missouri-kansas city because I had
the audacity to say that men are not
women this happened to a lot of other
conservative speakers and when the
students get rowdy guess what happens
instead of the administration saying
listen students you should hear out
other ideas and form your own opinion
what do they say they say good go we
stand with you it's awful that those
student that those conservative speakers
came to campus huge embarrassment for
Oberlin College right now symptomatic of
a larger embarrassment for all of these
American universities and it shows you
this important truth about the left and
coulter actually told me this when I was
in college keep this in your mind know
it in all political debates when the
left calls you racist you know you've
won the argument we will explain and
examine a key aspect of this from the
2020 race plus we've got to get to Joe
Biden's big flip-flop and the Democrats
Watergate flop but first coming up
tonight at 7:30 p.m. Eastern 4:30 p.m.
Pacific tune into our next episode of
daily wire backstage daily wire god-king
jeremy boring little ol me ben shapiro
andrew Clavin and this week's special
guest dave rubin will be sipping whiskey
smoking stogies and figuring out how to
not have all of our shows taken off the
air which is a daily threat that we are
now getting from
YouTube and other platforms as always
only daily wire subscribers get to ask
the question so be sure to subscribe
right this minute why else should you
subscribe you give me you get the intro
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get them out wall show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get
another Kingdom you get to ask questions
backstage you get the leftist tears
tumblr oh that's good that sounds like a
tastes like the 2016 polls you know
you've got to age them sometimes leftist
tears tastes better with a little bit of
age so you age them for about three
years and those polls that show mmm
Hillary has a 99% chance of winning
that's good mmm Hillary's gonna get
three hundred twenty three electoral
votes mmm that's good
mmm it's like a little it's a little
indulgence because none of it happened
go to daily we're calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
when the left calls you racist you know
that you've won the argument
kirsten gillibrand is the latest
Democrat to expose this eternal truth so
kirsten gillibrand who's pulling it like
negative three percent right now she is
the most extreme Democrat candidate on
the question of abortion she's trying to
stake out this ground for herself and
she can't defend her ideas she can't
defend her defensive or her support for
abortion up until the moment of birth so
she's resorting to the left old strategy
of calling anyone who opposes her racist
here she is and I think it's it's wrong
to deny women basic reproductive freedom
and basic human rights you said you're
worried about judicial independence but
imposing a litmus test on your nominees
has long been seen as right an
encroachment on judicial independence I
mean are you doing I think there's some
issues that have such moral clarity that
we have as a society decided that the
other side is not acceptable imagine
saying that it's okay to appoint a judge
who's racist or anti-semitic or
homophobic telling asking someone to
appoint someone who takes away basic
human rights of any group of people in
America I think that we are we've we've
I don't think those are political issues
anymore and we believe in this country
and the separation of church and state
and I respect the rights of every
American to hold their religious beliefs
true to themselves but our country and
our Constitution has always demanded
that we have a separation of church and
state and all these efforts by President
Trump and other ultra radical
conservative judges and justices to
impose their faith on Americans is
contrary to our Constitution and that
that's what this is and so I believe
that for all of these issues they are
not issues that there is a fair other
side there is no moral equivalency when
you come to racism
and I do not believe there's a moral
equivalency when it comes to changing
laws that deny women reproductive
freedom so that's a big old word salad
until she gets to the end point which is
she says if you oppose killing a baby at
the moment of birth you're basically
just like a racist and that view should
be kicked out of society she starts out
and she says I believe in religious
freedom you say well first of all no you
you don't I I bet she doesn't believe in
religious freedom for the Baker who
wants to not participate in events that
that go against his religion which
probably doesn't support that so much
but she says I believe in religious
freedom and we don't have we have a
separation of church and state and so
abortions just a question of religion
first of all it's not a question of
religion it's a question of what is a
baby is the baby a baby if the baby is
not a baby is that some other kind of
animal if the baby is not a baby is that
not alive we know it's alive we know
it's human we know it's an individual so
it's a baby but but that's a scientific
question she wants to pretend it's a
religious one then she says Donald Trump
is trying to force his faith on
Americans does anybody really believe
that Donald Trump is some devout
Christian going to church every Sunday
and praying all the time and I I don't
think so I think he's a lapsed
Presbyterian probably I think no one
ever said that Donald Trump was some
Christian zealot before he was the
president most people don't say it now
because it's it's crazy
then she lands on her actual answer
which is some ideas should be totally
prohibited from public discussion that's
what she's saying she's saying the
pro-life argument any pro-life argument
to say you shouldn't kill a baby the day
before it's born should be banned from
public discussion it is equivalent to
saying that black people are less than
white people that they should be
excluded from society to support not
killing a baby even at the moment of
birth is the same as being a racist and
if you support that then you're a racist
this is a very bad idea 94% of Americans
oppose late term abortion 94% kirsten
gillibrand and other Democrats have now
staked out a position for themselves
that 94
of Americans opposed in fact I think the
six percent who don't oppose it are
basically just all the Democrat
candidates for president
six percent of Americans support her
position worse than that she is now
accusing ninety-four percent of
Americans of basically being racists or
of holding a view that is the equivalent
of racism and that is unacceptable and
that nobody should be allowed to hold an
America the view that a baby who's about
to be born
shouldn't be killed that's the view this
is an extremism that is not going to
serve them well in the general election
it's part of a broader abortion
extremism that we're seeing among
Democrat candidates
Joe Biden is now showing this Joe Biden
used to be the moderate candidate he was
trying to stake out his position as the
moderate now he's flip-flopping on the
Hyde Amendment and the Hyde Amendment is
an old law which prohibits taxpayer
funding for abortion or that's what it
says it does it actually doesn't do that
in America we give Planned Parenthood
over half a billion dollars a year and
the way that we say though it's not
violating the Hyde Amendment is that we
say that money is only going toward the
non abortion services so you can't use
any of the taxpayer money for the
abortion services at the abortion clinic
you can only use it to pay the
electricity bill or to keep the lights
on or wanted to keep the cable
subscription or whatever obviously money
is fungible so if you give money to an
organization and you say spend that
dollar on one product but not on another
that's meaningless money is totally
interchangeable but that's at least the
way that Democrats have convinced us
that we're not paying for for abortion
services as taxpayers so Joe Biden
supported that measure at least he said
okay at least a name we can't have taxes
go to abortion now he's changed us to I
can't justify leaving millions of women
without access to the care they need and
the ability to construe exercise their
constitutionally protected right if I
believe health care is the right as I do
I can no longer support an amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone Zipcar see his chain of thought
what he said is if I believe that health
care is a right and
I also believe that abortion is
healthcare I mean that's the new
Democrat line used to be abortion should
be safe legal and rare now Miley Cyrus
elects a cake that says abortion is
healthcare and I licked a cake that said
taxation is theft which you can see on
the internet but that's a side point so
if you believe those two things abortion
they're rather health care is a right
which is a meaningless statement what is
it what does it mean health care is a
right health care is a commodity it
costs money do you have a right to
someone else's property do you have a
right to someone else's labor no it's a
meaningless statement but the Democrats
have adopted that one they started to
adopt that in about 2008 and if you
believe that abortion is health care
which again obviously it isn't shirring
health care for the baby that you're
killing if you believe those two things
then you have to logically conclude that
abortion is a right guaranteed by the
government and therefore paid for by the
government so you start out with two
faulty premises you're going to get to a
faulty conclusion garbage in garbage out
and Joe Biden is spewing that garbage
out of his mouth from the campaign trail
and this is alienating a lot of his
prospective voters there are a lot of
people who are anti Trump never Trump
moderates conservatives who hate the
president whatever who probably could
convince themselves to vote for Joe
Biden Joe Biden's been around for a long
time he seems kind of moderate he seems
kind of stable we all know who he is I
mean the key constituency here is the
McCain family which is a moderate sort
of Republican family that obviously
hates Donald Trump largely for personal
reasons and Megan McCain was on the view
and she said but this puts her in a
really tough spot because now she
doesn't think she can support Joe Biden
the moment was historically a great
compromise between pro-choicers and
pro-lifers and if you don't know what it
means it means that it bans federal
funding for abortions except in the case
of rape and incest so the government
won't be funding abortions and I think
for him he was for it for 40 years and
to make this flip and there's reports
out that said it was Alyssa Milano
calling him the actress and him getting
pressure from people like that and for
me everyone knows how much I love Joe
Biden as a person he's a he
truly the most decent person running in
in my opinion I think flip-flopping on
something like this
I actually was surprised by it because
he's filling the moderate compromise
Lane as the candidate and you're not
going to out progressive progressives if
Democrats want a progressive they're
gonna go with Elizabeth Warren or
they're gonna end up going with Cory
Booker or someone that's so much further
to the left so he's alienating the lane
that he that I still see as the the
easiest way to be President Trump and
you're alienating a lot of moderates and
especially for pro lifers like me this
is this is kind of a shot fired so Megan
McCain saying I really want to vote for
Joe Biden but this is too far I can't
use my money as a tax payer to pay for
abortions we're all already doing it by
the way but she said I can't if I lose
that fiction at least that I'm not not
spending my own money on abortion I
can't vote for you this is a Joe Biden's
big problem he he's not a politician who
stands for something he's just kind of
nothing he's just there he was just
there in 1988 he was just there in 2008
he's just there now which is why I don't
believe the polls that say that he's
gonna trounce Donald Trump by 13 points
or something like that it's just flopped
the best-laid schemes of democrats often
go awry one of those happened in
Congress just this week that when they
had been promoting this for a couple
weeks now the Democrats in Congress said
we're gonna call John Dean a witness
from Watergate and he's gonna testify
and tell us how much like Watergate the
Trump administration is this is gonna be
huge testimony they were so excited for
those of you by the way who don't know
who John Dean is John Dean was White
House Counsel for Richard Nixon he was
involved in the Watergate affair he
ended up flipping testifying against
Richard Nixon he's a convicted felon and
he's just made a career at this point
out of attacking other Republicans he
testified before Congress it was just a
total flop here was Republican Matt
gates who I was actually criticizing a
little earlier for his environmental
stuff here is Matt Gaetz
really shining giving an a
Plus performance and exposing what a
ridiculous sideshow this testimony was
today in this hearing with the ghost of
Christmas past because the chairman of
the committee has gone to the Speaker of
the House and sought permission to open
an impeachment inquiry but she has said
no and so instead of opening the
impeachment inquiry into Donald Trump
which is what the Chairman wants to do
and what I presume a majority of
Democrats want to do we're here
reopening the impeachment inquiry
potentially in the Richard Nixon sort of
playing out our own version of that 70s
show and and what I really regret it is
a mystery major as a prop you are
functionally here as a prop because they
can't impeach President Trump because
70% of Democrats want something that 60%
of Americans don't a total flop and he
is being used as a prop and the
testimony was a total flop it fell flat
you probably didn't even hear about the
testimony and why is that because it
didn't offer anything new I mean since
Watergate this guy John Dean has spent
most of his time comparing Republican
politicians to Richard Nixon during the
George W Bush era he published three
books on this very accusation he
published one during the bush era called
worse than Watergate published another
one conservatives without conscience
published another one broken government
how Republican rule destroyed the
legislative executive and judicial
branches it seems to me we've heard this
song before his whole career is just at
first he was a rat and then he smeared
his friends and his former allies and
now just all Republicans again another
bad strategy for Democrats another
reason that I don't believe these bowls
coming out let's say that Democrats are
gonna trance Trump the Muller thing is
over it's over Donald Trump colluded
with the Russians it's a cover-up it was
a stolen election it's over you lost you
lost even if you want to argue about
obstruction which Donald Trump was
practically exonerated on obstruction
but even if you want argue about that
the collusion thing is done Muller found
no collusion
Rosenstein bar nobody found any
collusion that's over you lost and
Democrats are not going to win 2020 by
real it
the relitigated of 2016 the Muller
report the Mulder investigation was
trying to re-litigate the 2016
presidential election now they're trying
to relitigate the real litigation look
ahead guys you've got to look to 2020 if
you want a chance to win not that I care
I don't I don't care if Democrats win or
I don't want them to win so that's fine
keep doing what you're doing I do want I
don't want to conclude this without
getting to a couple polls that I do sort
of believe we started with those Trump
polls here are a few primary polls that
I think are sort of interesting
especially one of these it's bad news
for bethe O'Rourke new polls put bado
O'Rourke at just 2% remember beta was
the new thing he had the cover of Vanity
Fair that's when I knew the beta was
going to lose by the way Vanity Fair
does not tend to pick winning candidates
and they had the cover there and bado
said I was born for this I was born to
be in this race well the new polls say
that he wasn't born to be in it here's
Beto's reaction look there is a lot of
time before the Iowa caucus
we've never been guided by a poll before
if you were to look at the Texas Senate
race the first couple months after we
were in no poll was gonna say that we
were going to win that right no poll
said you were gonna win and then you
didn't win so I guess the polls were
right sorry bado
bad news it doesn't look like he's going
to be able to resurrect his campaign
because Peabody judge crawled inside of
Beto's body ripped out his intestines
and ate his soul so there are other bad
polls for Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
has been consistently ranked number one
or number two in the Democrat pack now
he has been overtaken in a new poll by
conducted by The Economist and YouGov
and who is beating Sanders as of now
Elizabeth Warren
so Elizabeth Warren is now got 16% of
Democrats support edging out Sanders at
just 12% why is this how is it possible
that Pocahontas is winning
she's unlikable that's absolutely true
but she's not a hundred years old Bernie
is somewhat likable but he's just
ancient he's just old news Elizabeth
Warren is also much smarter than
Bernie's
enders I mean just her on Raw IQ she's
just smarter
she's also more mainstream than Bernie
Sanders Bernie has been an independent
or a socialist his entire life except
for the brief moments when he identifies
as a Democrat to run in their primaries
she's a woman so in this time of
intersectional politics and victim
politics she can claim that I think that
helps and while she's unlikable she
doesn't seem evil she just seems
annoying
and I think that is enough to help
propel her a little bit I still don't
really think she's going anywhere but
really a tough news from polls that are
probably more likely to be correct I
mean these are polls that are tracking a
very particular thing in a short period
of time the the first Democrat debates
are about to happen
they're just tracking how the Democrats
are faring among Democrats that's very
different than trying to take some
national poll of some random candidate
that no one's ever heard of and put him
up nationally against Donald Trump when
there hasn't been a primary there hasn't
been anything like a general election so
I think though the left probably should
not take too much solace in the general
election polls but they they probably
could be a little bit worried about
those primary polls because at the
moment their front-runner is weak you've
got surging candidates and none of them
are terribly likable that's our show we
got a lot more to get to but you'll have
to ask it on backstage then get your
mailbag questions in for tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today we you
know Congress wants to give itself a
raise and Alexandria kzo Cortes has been
at the forefront of this fight insisting
that she needs a raise because if she
doesn't get a raise then what's gonna
happen is that congressmen are gonna end
up being corrupt if they don't get a
raise I want to explain why that
argument is insane and also I have a
different idea about what we might do
about congressional pay which I will
share with you all so justin trudeau
there's a video of him babbling
nonsensically and I want to play that
for you on the show today just because
it's I mean really funny honestly
and finally 60% of male managers say
that they're uncomfortable with women
working around women in the workplace
and working one-on-one with women gee I
wonder why we'll try to get to the
bottom of that mystery today over on the
Matt Walsh show